Clap bonjour!
Vous avez bien compris le clap d'aujourd'hui n'est pas anodin puisque on va faire une vidéo fact sur de vrais faux - en rapport avec le
mentalisme - avec Amixem. Je suis allé à Angers
précisément pour aller faire ça. Mais à la fin de cette vidéo Amixem va devoir répondre à trois questions. Trois questions
personnelles. Il aura le droit à un ou deux jokers. Pour lui un joker ce sera la possibilité de mentir.
Et forcément ce sera à vous de déterminer
quand est-ce qu'Amixem ment ou quand est-ce qu'il ne ment pas. Mais dans un premier temps on va se téléporter chez
lui. ah bah oui, bonjour
ça a pris tellement ils savaient pas ouais et eux non plus il t'avait pas vu dans le titre ni sur la vignette ni dans la
description.
-Ah oui non il avait à m****.
Allez, première facte. Plus on baille longtemps,
plus ça veut dire qu'on a un gros cerveau alors moi j'ai lu un livre assez géniale qui s'appelle votre
Cerveaux est
cf notre vidéo quand on bâille ce qu'on est fatigué juste apprendre un truc assez fou coucou
c'est un espèce de mécanismes automatiques qui fait qu'on a besoin d'air en fait beaucoup de bien pour y offrir
l'accès n'est en fait pas ça
du coup ça n'a rien à voir avec la taille
c'est faux
et bien c'était complètement ouvrez et bien ça fait complètement chier c'est qu'on est fatigué parce que notre cerveau est en surchauffe aux accents rock
du terme d'accor et donc plus tu
inspires d'air qui va le refroidir et donc si tu as un gros cerveau tu as besoin de faire un appel d'air beaucoup plus grand
crayon ou un tuteur je vais faire des siennes à voir comme au géant a vécu aussi
si c'est un crayon jeune attaquant ça si c'est un leader je les graver sur la table
Suivant le cerveau est l'organe le plus gros de notre corps
ah non le plus gras j'écris très mal
c'était très compliqué comme question j'étais en mode les poumons l'air il a compté je sais pas non c'est faux c'est faux oui
évidemment que c'est vrai c'était mon équipe et moi c'est en fait il est gras à
60% 60% du cerveau c'est du gras suivant on utilise seulement
17,3 pour cent de notre cerveau ça me paraît très crédible comme stade c'est vrai et bien c'est faux
alors non mais c'est faux mais chez un peu bâtard parce que il ya une légende urbaine qui dit qu'on n'utilise que 10% de notre
cerveau mais ça c'est complètement faux
d'accord et je suis je vais je vais lui faire un facteur peu fou aussi mais avec un chiffre très précis mais oui pourquoi 17
qui a pu prouver ça avec mes personnages je suis ta bile mais si on n'utilise jamais 100% de notre cerveau en même temps
quand on utilise sans entrain de les avoir tous mais exactement sait jamais en même temps les risques suivants on peut apprendre des données en
les écoutant durant son sommeil
alors si c'est fou je suis très déçu
moi j'avais fait ça une fois en plus j'avais lu mon cours et je l'avais enregistré sur le t3 je l'avais écouté en dormant
ça avait duré dix minutes je n'avais pas dormir mais
dans la théorie c'est tellement bien tu te dit vas-y j'ai pas réviser pendant la nuit je vais réviser grâce à l'école devrait s'intégrer inconsciemment
eh bien je dis que c'est vrai c'est faux mais merde si c'est une légende urbaine
mais je pense que si vraiment ça marchait depuis longtemps on le saurait on aurait des nous vendrait des cassettes
des cassettes putain les mecs et de 1982
C'est mon coach france amateur goldsman et pour apprendre à l'époque où j'y croyais et je m'étais fait une cassette automne hiver ce
walkman tarifs pour essayer d'apprendre comme ça bon je vais commencer à réfléchir à partir de maintenant suivant en 2015 un
puissant superordinateur eu besoin de 40 minutes pour simuler une seconde activité du cerveau humain c'est vrai c'est totalement vrai yes
mais oui c'est très intéressant cette vidéo abonnez vous suivant la longueur des terminaisons nerveuses d'un adulte fait 5
8 millions de kilomètres ce chiffre est extrêmement précis dont
C'est mon téléphone
allô c'est raccord avec le walkman donc à temps c'est tout les terminaisons nerveuses d'un être humain d'un adulte mis bout-à-bout ou à fait
singulière de 8 millions de kilomètres non non c'est beaucoup c'est faux et bien c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai ces superbes vêtements vrai et ça fait 5 45 fois le tour de la terre c'est incroyable nous ne faisons
Pas cela qui polit car suivant vous fait vous faut un
élève a hypnotisé un professeur à son oral sa veste une dictée c'est faux je te dis fabien
statistiquement samedi que ce soit arrivé un mec qui feinte qui fore ya un sermon dû le faire au moins une fois
je te comptabilise le verse le potentiellement ça a pu arriver on ne le sait pas voilà je vous en fait
dû se trouver des failles que suivant
la bosse des maths existe réellement physiquement la bosse des maths
c'est faux pour toi c'est faux c'est chier et bien c'est faux
yes c'est faux s'est posé complètement fou que ça date d'une époque où on faisait de la phrénologie d'accord la phrénologie c'est une
pseudoscience où tu accélères quelques mois des frais et des tu freines
menace et s était une pseudo science mais qu'est vraiment le mec avait lancé ça comme une science il s'appelait france gall
rien à voir avec la chanteuse
Meilleures anecdotes de la vidéo suivant un cheval
mentalist a arnaqué tout un pays un cheval mentalist ouais donc le gars de profession fallu le cas de profession cheval
mentale et de hobby mentalist
arnaquer tout un pays mais j'ai très envie de dire que c'est vrai tellement c'est improbable pourquoi tu réécris un truc si improbable sinon
bien sûr que c'est vrai j'en ai même fait une vidéo que vous pouvez retrouver en cliquant sur red fish ici ou ici que je
n'ai pas vu du courbet peu de monde la vie ça date de l'année dernière
plus vers le lancement de la chaîne suivant le programme stargate a vraiment existé
cuivre de deux choses plus légères qui ça c'est vrai c'est vrai porte des étoiles à exister donc selon toi
mais fabien
statistiquement magasins agences spatiales qui sait dire est ce que tu as accès à tous les dossiers
déclassifiés classifiés un bien c'est vrai tafer reyes en 1995 la cia
faisait des recherches sur la manipulation mentale et sa série appelée stargate le projet stargate donc là rien à voir mais
l'essai sur la manipulation mentale c'est pour ça que c'est comme ça les portes
ils ont été déclassifiés en 2017
suivant il ya autant d'appareils connectés à internet dans le monde que deux neurones dans un cerveau d'ailleurs comme ça qu'ils se font des attaques
par déni de service mais qui à 10 milliards d'appareils connectés
donc ouais ça sonne bien de neuro de ça c'est vrai c'est faux
merde c'est pas combien il ya de ne rentrer dans un cerveau qu'on n'a jamais compté mais ça n'a jamais quand et
non on sait avant on disait qu'elle est 100 milliards aujourd'hui on sait que c'est moins on dit qu'il ya
86 milliards donc entre 86 milliard et cent milliards de neurones dans un camp même du manège fois plus là on est on est bien
bien loin suivant giordano bruno ont chanté connaît non et bien c'est le scientifique qui a réussi à convaincre
l'église que l'univers est un film qu
il y a dû prendre des risques qu'il a réussi à les convaincre que l'univers était un film
est surtout un petit singe qui souriaient à la fin
du world art bien sûr il aurait
il été bon c'est faux très bien c'est faux si pour ces faux alors c'est pas dur dano ses six filles
effectivement essayé de convaincre l'église et tout le monde que le sida continue où il s'est fait brûler
ce qui me semblait
ah ben ça pouvait pas finir bien ce truc simple que ça.
suivant !
le mot robot a été inventé en 1920 par la première intelligence artificielle pour se nommer elle même.
Ce serait tellement nous y habituer quoi je suis à robot en 1920 s'il te plait
1920 précisément
Et la date est précise.
C'est faux.
ça c'est faux, c'est complètement faux parce que la classe est complètement faux mais en
1920 il ya une pièce de théâtre aux tchèques de karel capek
qui représentait en fait des travailleurs
artificielle d'accord tu vois qu'il y en ait qui était un peu humanoïdes ailleurs qui faisait les sages que celle de la science fiction
ouais c'est ça et avec des intelligences artificielles
et c'est lui qui a inventé ça il appelait ça des robots tas ok ok qui en
tchèque veut dire servitude d'accord et du coup le mot robot vient de là
c'est très intéressant que la typologie suivant une connexion entre deux neurones ne disparaît jamais naturellement ça doit bien les tentes
Statistiquement
est bien une petite collection sur 10 milliards bon alors voilà je peux pas vrai quand les 10 milliards qui tiennent
et qu'elles soient rompus que par l'alcool jeudi que les connexions peuvent disparaître autrement que dans l'alcool la drogue naturellement oui c'est correct
Je te pose trois questions tu vas devoir dire la vérité à elle
seule de ces trois questions et vous vous devez chercher sur les techniques que vous voulez quand est ce qu'il dit la vérité
j'enlève minuad à un maximum de joueurs
on vous donnera la réponse sur twitter décide de trois jours vous pouvez suivre un mix entre le lien de sa chaîne de toute manière
exemplaire dans la description et le lien de mon twitter de la description où vous n'avez jamais cliquer en haut
C'est pas gentil mais on vous donnera sa voix sur twitter dc dc de trois jours première question oui
quel est ton plus gros mensonge tu peux réfléchir un peu je
alors le plus gros mensonge que j'ai fait dans ma vie c'est lorsque en fait j'étais à l'école primaire
et que j'ai mis le feu à l'école et
à l'école ouais normal c'est vraiment une bonne journée
j'ai mis le feu à l'école et j'ai menti à tout le monde donc copains copines
maîtresse maman finlande en disant que c'était pas moi tu as plus grosse honte c'est quand
J'ai pris discrètement en photo norman de norman fait des vidéos
et comme un fanboy et qu'on m'a vu et c'était hyper gênant
J'ai totalement pris en scred comment facebook vraiment le fanboy de base
ne va pas vu mais d'autres gens m'ont vu c'était gênant
truc le plus what the fuck que tu en rapport avec youtube alors un fact incroyable à propos de youtube
c'est que pour ceux qui regardent la chaîne de cyril super connard il a une porte secrète à sa droite tu vois
voilà et bien c'est parce que quand tu lourd c'est cette porte là
et c'est mon studio ça voudrait dire que c'est un studio communs existent là
c'est ça que ça voudrait dire
si mme hâtivement et peut y avoir un couloir mais voilà
que j'ai vu en arrivant et qu'on a mangé tous en chambre ce midi du coup ce serait clairement se serait passé c'est ça
qu'est une vérité de mon sens il ya une seule vérité dans le tas c'est ce que vous devez trouver en fait la
vérité on arrive oui
ça égalé encore le feu
tout est lié je
regarde ce qui me prend en photo
on a fait une vidéo ensemble cet été sur des factures est faux mais sur nous
oui si oui et sur ta chaîne ou alors regarde moi je connais très bien la vie à l'ewi
je ne sais jamais maintenant que je le sais je le
vois là
j'adore l'utiliser mais cette vidéo est très cool parce qu'on apprend plein de choses sur toi et même sur - oui tout à fait c'est
une sorte de faq vrai ou faux monde chinoises et dans les commentaires en plus de chercher ou escales mix m a dit la vérité
vous pouvez aussi me dire à quel youtuber vous aimeriez que je fasse ça ou sur quel autre sujet mais toujours un port avec le
mentalisme
non c'est vraiment marrer à faire ça moi le premier donc si ça vous plaît n'hésitez pas à me le dire en explosant la barre
des pouces en l'air
auquel cas je ferai d'autres vidéos sur cette série merci encore à un mix m de m'avoir reçu abonnez-vous à lui si ce n'est pas
encore fait et nous on se retrouve toujours les mardis et les vendredis à 15 heures et le dernier mercredi du mois à 20h20 pour
le live à très bientôt chao pour grover
vrai ou faux en appuyant sur le cercle là qu'il ya au centre avec avec ma photo on peut s'abonner
même depuis un téléphone vrai ou faux le meilleur moyen de le savoir c'est d'essayer de le faire fait le coup ça vous serez